oh
no it's so bad
dude she's all blue they're all blue hey
guys it's max angelica and vadim and
today we are doing another blind camera
comparison with the new pixel 6 pro
against the iphone 13 pro max so over
the weekend max took a ton of photos
with both of these phones at his hot
springs trip and we have no idea which
one is which we're going to be choosing
so go ahead and get a piece of paper and
a pen play along with us right now
that's always fun when you guys are
joining yeah it's way more fun when we
read your comments too and we see what
you get so let us know all right guys
here is the first photo with the sunrise
while you're looking at i have to say
i'm super excited because google for
three years did not change their sensors
at all it was just software they finally
did it and they went all out which one
do you guys like all right so the left
one you can obviously see more in the
shadows however the one on the right it
really kind of makes the sun rise pop
all the the color of the water pop so
i'm i think i'm going to choose that one
on the right yeah it seems like some of
the details are crushed on the right but
overall it's just way more dynamic when
the one on the left is so flat pleasing
moody yeah all right guys let's see if
you're apple fans or pixel fans just
kidding this is only the start and that
is the iphone it's weird seeing more
contrast yeah usually pixel used to have
way more doesn't do that
all right we got a standard shot right
here with the landscape fancy
and this one honestly i think i like the
one
on the right because once again the
colors are popping if you look at the
trees on the left they're all kind of
flat
faded everything's flat but you get more
kind of i guess
pop of color i don't know
yeah the right
i don't know if it's the sharpness or if
it's just like the darks being brought
down but like the tree it looks a little
unrealistic
but overall it does look better than the
left one
and that one is the pixel 6 pro
i think with this one i like the one on
the right more i feel like i see more
detail
really
the one on the left just looks kind of
over sharpened and a little unrealistic
i think i like the one on the left i
think it's less faded and
i kind of do see some good detail i
don't know i like it all right you guys
are disagreeing and let's see so the one
on the right is the pixel
and 13 pro max on the left
and here we have a macro shot
oh geez wow the one on the left
i like that one it just pops so much
more that looks really good i like that
these are like complete polar
that's so opposite
so one of these phones has a macro mode
yep
right one attitude crop
so here you go
yep
how do you do a macro shot in old
iphones and old samsung pixels you have
to crop um where iphone has a macro mode
but of course it uses the ultra white so
you don't have that nice blur and that
gives you that pop interesting
all right we got a selfie here the first
one portrait mode i'm really liking the
one on the left more it looks a lot more
natural the one on the right the blur
just seems so intense and just the
cutout it just looks so fake oh yeah
that's it that is a good point the blur
is more intense and i do like the extra
bokeh on the left and the more kind of
warm face i definitely like that
compared to the right which is kind of
flat
that is the iphone
we have a lot more portrait shots i know
against the samsung it did really well
with portraits so here
we got another shot i won't comment
anything that's the right yeah right
is it that big of a difference it's
massive it's massive that is the pixel 6
pro looks so good this is actually a uh
this is a 15 times zoom shot that's the
most that the iphone can do the pixel
can actually go to 20 and it has a 48
megapixel
four times optical camera i mean
the detail difference is clear and we
got a portrait shot here all right this
is a little bit of a tough one but i am
gonna have to go with the right because
it looks like the one on the left is
kind of over sharpened and the contrast
is turned up too high like this hdr
effect whereas that one looks much more
natural i think so yeah right right for
sure and that is the iphone so it's
interesting that that zoom lens the
telephoto lens that we just talked about
it can't be used for portrait shots
really so it's only using the main lens
once again right right easily easy and
this is not the telephoto camera this is
the main camera cropped in so we're
checking for detail wow and apple's been
sticking around with 12 megapixels for a
long time forever this thing has a 50
megapixel main camera that samples down
to 12. you guys can see the detail
that's impressive and this was an
extreme dynamic range shot like it was
crazy on the bridge with the sun and the
clouds i've got to say i hate the photo
on the left for some reason
it does not it doesn't look right
yeah
the one on the left is a really good job
of bringing up the shadows but it's all
just so flat compared to the one on the
right where you have the little ranges
like the dark spots the bright spots it
looks more like natural light yeah this
this looks so weird essentially i
thought you guys would like the one on
the left better but that's good that is
the iphone more contrast once again
here's the next one we get a portrait
shot a wider one now i'm liking the one
on the right way more it's like way
sharper all the details are like nice
and focused his hair i hate how
everything is just so flat on the left
yep i agree i noticed the one on the
left is kind of like faded like if you
look at look at his shoe it's really
faded and like washed out
so they're very similar but i'm also
going with the right i like the contrast
and that is the pixel
it flips
yep and then we got ultra wide shot
um it's hard to tell here but the
dynamic range difference was crazy
because it's back lit with shadows it's
got to be the left left one love the
color of the oh yeah the water like the
blue water so nice yeah and also i like
that you could actually see all the
details in the brick that's in this case
you want it to be flatter you don't want
all that to be crushed and that is the
pixel once again
with the
taking it out of ultra
park and the blue water actually was not
that blue
so i had more shots but each time it
kicks the water up it knows what that is
it looks good we got a selfie shot here
so this time we it's not um portrait
mode just regular oh
left the right one is just so blown out
and it's just
fading everywhere exactly the one on the
right if you look at your face it's all
flat yep here you actually see the
different tones of the brightness kind
of the highlight roll off it's better
with the hdr and i think just and you
know what's interesting usually it's
nice if you have better hdr the faces
are flat
or you have more contrast on the faces
than hdr sucks but this one's better in
every single way and it's the pixel
once again this was actually an extreme
under the bridge it was super bright out
there this is an extreme test and it did
great all right we got a portrait shot
here a wide shot i'm going with the left
first of all i like that um i like the
the coat like all the detail and the
fluffy thing and her face is kind of
more brought up but it's not like
doesn't look weird
and the depth is more natural whereas
this is just like it looks fake it's
like sharp
yeah i love everything about the right
photo except for the blur it's just
there's too much it looks fake other
than that i would have picked it you got
it i have to have to choose the left one
left okay that is the iphone very
natural blur nice all right we have a
shot here an action shot with extreme
action
these are both these were taken at the
same exact time no delay between them
i'm gonna have to go with the left i
like that you kind of have more detail
on the shadows and the one on the left
was way better at like capturing them
and not blurring them out like a lot of
them here
like with the motion but the one on the
left was really good at that left thanks
six pro what yep the shot looks good but
it was interesting that it was about i
don't know it was a little bit behind
and i noticed that in other shots the
iphone takes a picture instantly that
one like waits a little bit but it got
it nice and sharp and we got a object
portrait shot here so no subject oh
right yeah i'm gonna go with the right
because that post is just way too cool
the color itself just ruined it for me
yeah it looks like the blur edging got
messed up right here in between this
little gap yeah yep so the one on the
right definitely killed it iphone yep
and i'll point out once again we have a
natural
gradient of port of blur like a real
camera over here it's like sharp sharp
and then boom and we have a portrait of
noah all right and this is the telephoto
portrait where you can what the heck
happened here look yeah oh it's totally
botched all of this even right here next
to his head that just ruined it for me
yeah left for sure 13 pro
i thought it was good at that stuff it's
it's tough with all of this all of these
crazy branches look at this chunk right
here
um yeah i guess iphone just got really
good at portraits now
and we got a regular shot under that
bridge crazy dynamic range
spider girls there oh my goodness the
one on the left just does such a better
job that is insane yeah it's so flat and
ruined wow
pixel 6 pro that dynamic range there
that is good maybe portraits aren't that
good but the dynamic range is really
good
and we gotta put some
oh oh oh
no it's so bad
dude she's all blue they're all blue
literally everything is just blue
so this is a oh no this is low light oh
and tough lighting there you guys go
what the [ __ ] the difference is massive
like you actually have all the different
colors and everything here
this one just fails so hard and it
wasn't a fluke i took multiple photos i
thought maybe there was a glitch or
something oh yeah
pixel 6 pro didn't do that well in that
mix crazy lighting night mode portrait
everything combined all right what do
you think
so you could go first
wow you're dramatic
it shouldn't be that hard to choose
right you guys like the left better
left looks nicer
wow oh my goodness wow the right is such
a good job in this case yeah a lot
better all that noise yeah the right is
easy and it's gonna choose the left are
you gonna it gets the colors out too i'm
sorry nika yeah i don't know what
happened here but the one on the left is
just so flat
tons of noise
garbage
you know what's weird is the iphone got
a really up updated ultrawide camera oh
it's ultra one yeah this is ultrawide
shot this is testing the one camera we
haven't tested detail yet and the pixel
it actually has a 12 megapixel as well
it doesn't go for a high res wow but in
this low light scene
it just did a lot better that's good and
now we got this bad boy for night mode
oh we're getting into the night stuff
the right right instantly yeah it's
better in every way
13 pro max so flips
yeah so if it's not a night mode if it's
just low light not in imode the pixel
does better but going into the night
mode
and we got a zoom shot boys and girls
just kidding
oh my goodness that is so good wow
that is so impressive how long do you
want to guess what that is
it's got to be the pixel of course yeah
i know the iphone can't do that you know
what's weird is that the iphone has a
three times zoom now instead of a 2x uh
or 2.5 this has a four it's not that
much but it's not 10x but of course that
is the pixel it looks so much better i
almost wonder if it's like the mirror
that it flips it or something because
the samsung also looked good
and we got this portrait shot right here
both phones did take a portrait shot i'm
i'm going with the left so the one thing
i like about the
right is that the tesla text is actually
colorful you know it brings out the
color however it just looks so distorted
and kind of weird compared to this looks
like a more natural
photo those look distorted
even though that's about i'm i'm still
going to the left left all right left is
the pixel 6 pro
so it blew out all the highlights it
actually did look just like that
remember the neon lights in your review
um and the iphone did do a portrait shot
the pixel actually would fail here it
was too close i couldn't do the portrait
it was super dark here with nice you
know bright little highlights lights
everywhere spotlight so it was a very
tough situation there's a lot more
detail on the one on the right a lot
more yep so one thing i can notice is in
this pavement you can see all the
texture whereas here it's all just
smeared out
and this does look too warm like all of
it is warm whereas this has different
color ranges popping out so right easy
this is the iphone and it's interesting
that it's more detail because it's only
a 12 megapixel compared to a 50 for that
standard lens and then we have a night
mode portrait shot so both of them could
combine those oh jeez this is tough
there's things i don't like about either
of these the one on the right just looks
really fake the colors look really off
the one on the left is nice i like the
blur but like some of the details are
really smeared
but i i still think i like the one on
the left way more the one on the right
just looks weird yeah in this case i was
gonna say that the one on the right has
more detail which it does however like
the skin tones everything just gets
ruined the background it's brought up
way too much too much it's so flat so
i'm also going yeah it's so flat over
here there's so much dimension over
there
13 pro max and i will say that the 12
per max and 11 it brought up the
background a lot more apple added more
contrast more dynamics for night mode
this year
and we have a night mode shot inside and
dim lighting sorry for those that don't
like moose
or whatever they call these things
all right for me in this case
i don't like how there's more noise on
the right however the detail
is just
so much better you have all the detail
in the hair you get the texture in the
wood texture and the brick so even
though the colors aren't as good and
there's more noise i'm still going with
the right
yeah i agree i hate this image
but i hate this one more yeah yeah
essentially this is like over sharpened
to me you guys already voted um and it's
brought up so much i like the moodiness
of this but the detail that it lacks so
bad like you don't even notice that one
back there
all right the pixel 6 pro then this is a
telephoto night mode shot so this one
actually zoomed into 4x as well to match
it okay um but there you go
and we're going to extreme low light now
okay i'm instantly choosing the one on
the left because you could actually see
stuff around him yeah look at that
doormat there however his face is just
eyes
i'm going with the one on the right
i'm going with the left because this one
is just way too black and dark i
actually took this photo multiple times
because he was standing super still but
everything just kept me getting so
smeared
i'm still going left even yeah this is a
little blurred yeah yeah you should go
with the one you already chose
pixel 6 pro it's interesting the iphone
made everything so and this was
extremely light like extreme yeah i'd
rather have that honestly and then we
get a nice scene with
skye
and of course both of these were super
dark wow this is just garbage yes it's
all flat there's no details no colors
here you actually get the colors and
it's more detailed
ten times better
that is the iphone and i have to comment
the iphone i took one image
this was i think a three second exposure
the pixel was like a seven or eight
second exposure and all the night mode
shots were at least twice as long at the
pixel and two twice it just would go out
of focus on a lot of these but i didn't
want to use out of focus one i was like
if it went out of focus you'd take
another photo so that was interesting
and we got a night mode selfie oh this
is like the worst
night mode selfie yeah what happened to
your face it's all red
iphone right there
once again it was just this was like i
don't know seven eight seconds or
something like that compared to i think
two oh man you got an ultra white right
here oh the one on the right yeah one on
the right oh gee definitely like i don't
even know if there's artifacts or noise
but it's just so just smeared and noisy
13 pro max
and i left one of each camera for the
extreme low light uh because i thought
it would be fair to test each one in
really dark modes
and then this is a standard lens left
yeah oh you said left i'm going right i
can see more detail on the leaves and i
like how the
the fence is more brought up i'm seeing
more detail on the leaves on the left
everywhere i'm seeing what shot would
you want in your i am older i mean i am
getting all the time
looks smeared to me this is detailed and
there you guys go you guys did not agree
on the last shot we got the iphone over
here
so there you go guys that is wow very
last shot
don't show it yet do not show it okay
guys
we need you guys to pause the video
count up what you got if you didn't yet
scroll back and just do a quick voting
it is so fun to see your guys's unbiased
opinions too um
and all right guys so we will have the
game go first let's hop with him go
first you ready i'm ready all right the
iphone got 16 the pixel got 14. it was
so close wow and i guess
a lot of them traded blows one would be
better at one thing of course the zoom
camera looks like the portraits are
better than the iphone angelica your
turn i got 15 for both i got it wow
which is crazy because in the first half
the pixel was beating it out by far but
then as soon as the night mode shots
came in they just caught back up so fast
wasn't the pixel the first phone that
had night mode
i feel like it was it was it blew
people's minds away maybe it was yeah so
okay guys well you guys let us know what
shocked you what surprised you what you
expected what you didn't want to hear
your guys's opinions of course your
scores too um with that said go ahead
and click that subscribe button above
you guys can help us reach our goal of a
million subscribers check out one of
those great videos right over there and
this has been max angelica and vadim
i'll mention your names for you i will
see you in the next video